you said you here to get me
here's the crisis is here I will be
running home
Batwoman there is no more time the
multiverse is in great danger I'm sorry
there what
I'm fighting to make things right
your people we need your help stopping
this antimatter ways you just told me my
world is over and you need my house
no one else has to die
come with me I need your help to avert a
crisis that threatens the entire
multiverse welcome to the joy zone
there's a wave of antimatter destroying
everything in its path until it
obliterates all reality we can beat this
together
Suda for the biggest crossover ever
we've got your backs
Lyceus on
the CW's crossover event begins Sunday
December 8th presented by boost mobile
should have told me what was going to
happen on earth-2
John was there he could have been killed
the destruction of that earth was a
necessary sacrifice what about Laurel
Lance her friends her family account was
more like than really perish if we do
not ensure that all of the coin is
prepared for what is coming were you
successful yes
I have dr. Juan
let us go see welcome back everyone big
surprise they dropped a bunch of new
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer video
so we'll break it all down there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs there's a
bunch of other scenes that aren't in
these trailers that I'll breakdown and
obviously we have that scene with lilah
confirming that she is the harbinger
character that's been working with the
monitor she's probably been Harbinger at
this whole time we're doing a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
trailers on the video they brought back
so much stuff just in this footage and
it's only a fraction of the stuff that's
happening during the crossover there's
obviously gonna be Easter eggs for every
possible thing TV show movie comic book
that you could possibly imagine
but I'll start at the beginning of the
footage and just go through shot by shot
so you start with the flash asking lilah
who's gone full Harbinger if the monitor
has sent her to get him because it's
time for crisis on Infinite Earths to
start is it time then they use the logo
transitions with the antimatter wave
just letting you know that everything is
being wiped from existence there's a
reference to the original marketing for
a comic book crisis worlds will live
worlds will die in the DC Universe will
never be the same
they've already wiped earth to off the
map and a couple others so far
obviously they're gonna get rid of a
whole bunch of others too but they
actually used that line of dialogue from
the comics in last year's crossover with
a psycho pirate character so I'm
wondering if he's gonna come back in
cameo again during this in some way
because psycho-pirate was a big crisis
comic-book character there's a lot of
battle scenes with them fighting some
unseen force running it's something off
of screen we do actually see them later
in the trailer fighting the actual
anti-monitor in a giant rock quarry they
just break that scene up throughout the
trailer a bunch of different times this
is a scene of what seems like Barry in a
regular clothes running on the cosmic
treadmill at STAR Labs hopefully
there'll be some references to the
actual comic book cosmic treadmill
because the one at STAR Labs is just a
super version of a treadmill it's not
the actual cosmic treadmill
this is Barry inside what seems like one
of the labs on supergirls earth 38 most
of the footage seems like it's from a
couple different episodes like them
fighting the anti-monitor probably from
later in the crossover but most of the
rest of this footage seems like it's
from the first episode of the crossover
because they're getting the call to
action from Lyla she's going around
grabbing everybody and a lot of the
other characters seem like they're
meeting other care
for the first time berry references
coming home to you that's the original
song that he's saying during season 3
Supergirl also sang that song at their
wedding ceremony during the crossover a
couple years ago there's another scene
of 90s flash Barry Allen's symbol broken
on the cosmic treadmill implying that
he's either died or somehow his costume
just got ripped to shreds hopefully they
do not kill him off then lila goes to
pick up bat woman she's on the same
earth as the flash and arrow so it's not
like she's hopping to another reality
she just in Gotham City this kind of
seems like it's a version of their Wayne
Manor I have not been watching that show
so I'm not totally sure whether or not
they're gonna bring that version of
Batman into the crossover the one Batman
that we know we're getting is the Kevin
Conroy Batman from Batman the Animated
Series he's kind of playing the older
80-something Batman from Batman Beyond
then you have the flash Cisco in pariah
going to pick up black lightning on his
earth and him just completely freaking
out what are you doing here wait you
need my help
this is one of the only times that you
see which earth they're on when they
flash this map of the multiverse it says
earth 73 that's actually a big reference
to 1973
the year that the Superfriends team-up
TV show was created and they're kind of
doing a version of Super Friends with
them all teaming up for the crossover
sort of a TV version of Justice League
they've also referenced Super Friends in
the pastor and crossovers to the Hall of
Justice is that building on the flash TV
show
we just haven't gone there in a couple
years then you see Black Lightning
interacting with heatwave and killer
frost at STAR Labs
this scene of Lyla freaking out on a
hospital bed seems like it's maybe when
she's starting to go full Harbinger from
the comics love this scene of Black
Lightning interacting with 90s flash
Barry Allen I'm so happy they're
bringing him back then Black Lightning
just lighting something up with his
powers Lyla goes to pick up the legends
who seem like they're just chilling out
in a sports bar over beers Ray Palmer
suiting up you see him in battle with
everyone else there's a bunch of Ray
Palmer all over this early footage but
remember he's also playing Kingdom Come
Superman during this we see heatwave and
killer frost together flash rogues
team-up moment it's been forever since
heatwave has been on the flash or inside
STAR Labs we get that funny one-liner
from Sara welcome to the funs though
then this is them a bum-rushing the
anti-monitor you can see his armor looks
a little bit different from the monitors
armor it's almost exactly like comic
book anti
monitor without the crazy helmet that he
wears on top but this is what his face
looks like when he's not wearing that
helmet remember we also got that footage
of this same quarry with a version of
the monitor with no facial hair or
mutton chops so I'm starting to wonder
if he's somehow connected to the
anti-monitor then in the last couple of
scenes this is actually pretty
interesting you see a version of
Superman's cape torn and hung up like a
flag waving in the wind just like during
the death of Superman after he had been
killed by doomsday but which version of
Superman's cape is it or Supergirl so
the thing is it's not Supergirl or earth
38 Superman's cape their capes look like
this in it's not Smallville Superman Tom
Welling scape his cape looks like this
we know Brandon Roth is playing an older
version of Christopher Reeve Superman
just because of the way the continuity
of Superman Returns works and his cape
is a little bit different from that
movie but this is Christopher Reeves
cape this is his cape during that movie
he's also playing Kingdom Come superman
wearing a version of that comic book
costume and this is what that cape looks
like so either this happens to be a
totally different version of Superman
that they wind up killing off on an
alternate earth and it's a big easter
egg for another version or issues from
an earlier battle but let me know in the
comments if you can spot which version
of Superman's cape this is from which TV
show which movie which comic book
reference because none of the capes I
can think of look exactly like this but
heads up they probably will kill off at
least one version of Superman during the
crossover but obviously because earth 38
Superman is getting his own TV show next
year it's definitely not gonna be him
then they have a team meeting on
supergirls earth heartfelt talk with
Superman and then some more that big
battle scene in the quarry with the
anti-monitor
the other new scenes that they reveal
but aren't in this trailer our
confirmation on baby John Kent Superboy
he'll be featured more on that Superman
TV show next year team Supergirl then
Lina Luthor and Alex helping out so Lina
in addition to Lex Luthor will
participate in at least the first
episode of the crossover Batwoman
Superman is Supergirl than all of the
actors from the first episode of the
crossover together just mugging for
camera this is them behind the scenes
Oliver the legends Mia Smoak the flash
Martian Manhunter the Supergirl
characters Ray Palmer and bat woman then
Oliver having a heart-to-heart chat with
earth thirty eight Superman Oliver and
Mia then bat woman Superman Ray Palmer
the
right in the middle of a fight but
what's gonna happen is is because all
the footage is starting to drop now
there'll be a much bigger trailer that
will probably drop sometime next week
because that's when all the shows come
back they were on break this week I know
a lot of you are still wondering what's
the deal with Tom Wellings Smallville
Superman what's he going to be doing
which of the crossover he is going to be
in yes there was a convention a little
while ago where someone implied that Tom
Welling said that he was only in a
couple scenes for the crossover it was
gonna be like a really huge role but he
would be doing something really cool so
just be sure to couch your expectations
in terms of how they use that Tom
Welling Superman character there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening they just
announced five brand new Marvel phase 5
mystery movies I'm doing a new Holt
video I'll talk about those movies when
I post that sometime in the next couple
of days while you wait for everything
click here for my last big crisis on
Infinite Earths trailer video and click
here for my brand new Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]